[Music]  good morning wife  [Music]  this is great look out your window no  I'm taking you away for the weekend I  just can't believe this is my life that  I get to live with you  that meant nothing to me before you  can--it greatest office we wanted to  welcome the new fiction editor I bought  it for us I should have asked you first  oh my god Christian this is Jim Matteo  the architect this location is perfect  I'm going to build you a fabulous house  please stop speaking of my husband as if  I weren't here Anna you may call me mrs.  grey I'll pick you up at 5:00 I may not  be done by  very follows  how the hell are you Anna  Jack what you want  so you want to play yes sir  I made a vow to love you faithfully  forsaking all others did you sleep with  her to comfort you when times of need  and to keep you safe  first office we both shall live  [Music]  you